- [Mark] Let me turn some lights on...
Boom.
- [Rebecca] Uh huh.
- [Mark] Okay, Rebecca, how are you?
- [Rebecca] Fine, you?
- [Mark] I'm great.
So what time is it? It's like 3:30-
- Right now, it's like almost
5 o'clock in the morning.
- [Mark] It's almost 5 in
the morning, you're right.
I've been here for an hour or so.
So I met you, how many, four years ago?
- Yeah, about right.
- [Mark] Four years ago
out here on Skid Row.
- And downtown.
- [Mark] How much money
do you make in a night?
- Sometimes...
Sometimes good money, sometimes, you know,
like every business.
- [Mark] But like tonight, it's raining.
- Yeah, right.
- [Mark] And you're out here
in the cold and the rain?
- Yes.
- [Mark] You're out here every night?
- Not really, no, not my regular job.
This is like a part-time.
- [Mark] Where's your other job?
- I work at Hollywood.
- [Mark] And what do you do?
- Housekeeping.
- [Mark] Really?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And when you're housekeeping,
you dress as a man or as a woman?
- I'm woman all 24 hours, always.
- [Mark] Yes, you're all woman?
= Uh huh.
- [Mark] All woman?
- No, not really, not yet.
- [Mark] Mostly woman?
- Not yet, almost yes.
(laughter)
- [Mark] That's cool.
And how long have you been doing this?
- How long? About...
18 years.
- [Mark] 18 years?
- Yes.
- [Mark] How much money
do you make in a night?
- Sometimes 300, 400,
500, 100, 200, depends.
- [Mark] And you pay taxes on that, right?
- Mhmm.
(laughter)
- Not really, no.
- [Mark] I don't blame you.
And you have family?
- My family is all in Mexico.
- [Mark] They're in Mexico? Do they know
that you're a woman?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And how do they feel about that?
- They're okay, there's not problem.
- [Mark] Because Latin American families,
don't-, they're not so
wild about that, I've seen.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Well, you're beautiful.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] You still look great.
- [Mark] You're what, 22, 23?
- What?
- [Mark] Years old.
- Oh, I wish!
(laughter)
- I have, like, right
now like 42 years old.
- [Mark] You're 42?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You look great.
You were blonde, the last
time I photographed you.
- Yes, I remember now, I'm
a redhead now, red color.
- [Mark] Yes.
- How my new look?
- [Mark] I like blondes.
- Yeah, really?
- [Mark] But redheads are great too.
You look great either way.
- Thank you, thank you.
- [Mark] Show me what
you're wearing tonight.
- What?
- [Mark] I want to see
what you're wearing.
Your very short skirt, right?
- [Rebecca] Very short
skirt, with red underwear.
- [Mark] Yes, I see.
- My pussy's wet too.
- [Mark] Really?
- Yes.
(laughter)
- Yes, it's very wet.
- [Mark] Okay.
So how long will you be out here?
You'll be out here until-
- I'm ready to work from 4
to 6.
- [Mark] 4 to 6, that's the-
- That's only two hours,
that's enough to me.
- [Mark] Why not earlier in the evening?
Why do you wait until 4:00am?
- [Rebecca] Oh, because I was sleeping,
watching TV, sleeping.
- [Mark] Oh so you wake up,
and this is your early morning?
- [Rebecca] I wake up, two
or three in the morning,
I'll be ready in like one hour,
to get there, to Skid Row, to work.
- [Mark] Oh.
- [Rebecca] Yeah.
- [Mark] And then from
here, you'll go where?
- [Rebecca] And I go to
my house to relax, sleep,
be ready for cleaning my
house, do laundry to be ready
for start work on Monday to Friday.
- [Mark] Excellent, and the
guys that pick you up are nice?
- [Rebecca] Yes guys, men.
- [Mark] Yeah, but
they're what kind of guys?
Are they kind and gentle?
Or they're kind of crazy
and drunk? Or they're...
- [Rebecca] Everything.
- [Mark] Everything.
Tell me a crazy story.
- [Rebecca] The most ones drunk
and drug addicts, you know.
They're high, smoking weed,
crystal, drinking beer.
You know, they want to have
a good time, that's all.
- [Mark] And they're...
They're white, they're
black, they're latino?
- They're all kind.
Black, white, Mexicans,
and some Chinese.
- [Mark] Really?
- [Rebecca] Yeah, all kinds.
- [Mark] A little bit of everything.
- [Rebecca] A little
bit of everything, yes.
But the most is of the latino guys.
- [Mark] Mostly latino?
- [Rebecca] Yeah, they're
looking for blowjob and
fuck ass.
(laughter)
Yes, that's what they're looking for.
- [Mark] Wow.
And they're probably married?
- [Rebecca] No.
- [Mark] No? Who knows?
- [Rebecca] No, he's
looking for fun, that's all.
- [Mark] None of my business.
What-
What are your dreams?
Where would you like to be in five years?
- Drink?
- [Mark] No, where would you
like to be? With your life.
Would you like to be
living in Beverly Hills?
Would you like to be...
- No, I wanna-
- [Mark] Married with kids? I'm joking.
- I'm moving to Hollywood next month.
- [Mark] You're moving to Hollywood?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Excellent.
- Was close to my job, that's
what I work, in Hollywood.
Hollywood and Highland.
Yeah. I working for LGBT
center and business center.
- [Mark] Oh great.
You used to live downtown, right?
- [Rebecca] I live on,
(unintelligible), by the West Side.
- [Mark] Yeah, I think I
gave you a ride home once.
- [Rebecca] Yes.
- [Mark] Excellent.
- Yes.
- [Mark] Well, thank you so
much for talking with me.
- No problem. Anytime you want something,
I'm ready to suck it.
(laughter)
- [Mark] You're sweet.
Thanks for the offer.
- No problem.
- [Mark] Alright.